bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde notre grand témoin ce soir et
l'un des écrivains les plus lus dans le
monde rendez-vous compte le pape
François a même écrit La Poste face de
son dernier livre bonsoir Éric-Emmanuel
Schmitt bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être
là le défi de Jérusalem chez Albin
Michel c'est votre récit de la
pèlerinage en Terre sainte un peu un
journal de bord un carnet de voyage que
le Vatican vous a proposé d'écrire c'est
une histoire incroyable et on va en
parler longuement tout à l'heure mais on
commence par le couple Macron borne au
lendemain de la onzième journée d'action
contre la réforme des retraites la
première ministre s'est confié dans la
presse et elle se projette à Matignon
mais veut surtout apaiser le pays et ne
pas humilier les syndicats des propos
qui contrastent avec ce tenue par le
chef de l'État à une semaine de la
décision cruciale du Conseil
constitutionnel Emmanuel Macron
Elisabeth borne un couple infernal ou
pas
la première ministre a-t-elle encore un
avenir à Matignon grand décryptage dans
un instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver à 20h15 les parties pris de
nos affranchis et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu vous me
suivez
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt c'est
[Musique]
aligner officiellement il n'y a aucune
dévergence entre les deux têtes de
l'exécutif mais la manière un peu
différente avec laquelle il s'exprime
sur la situation du pays à alimenter
toute la journée les interrogations sur
le couple Macron borne bonsoir Nathalie
segun soit merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste politique à l'opinion en
charge du suivi de l'exécutif Élisée et
Matignon bonsoir Benjamin Morel bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous
constitutionnalisme maître de conférence
en droit public à l'Université Paris de
ponthéon à ça on va revenir sur cette
décision du 14 avril c'est dans une
semaine bonsoir Elsa bonsoir Elsa
mondingavage journaliste politique à la
rédaction LCP vous suivez la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale enfin bonsoir
Stéphane zumsteg bons ravi de vous
recevoir directeur du département
politique et opinion à l'institut Ipsos
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt vous êtes écrivain
on est un peu loin de la spiritualité
mais c'est un peu du théâtre aussi la
politique et vous êtes aussi metteur en
scène en autre chose donc la scène
politique du moment est votre regard
nous intéresse alors qu'a dit la
première ministre pour que l'on
s'interroge autant sur sa stratégie il a
200 secondes pour nous le dire le chrono
de Blacko c'est parti
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
Stéphane bakowski bonsoir bonsoir à
toutes et tous alors alors aujourd'hui
tout le microcosme politique est en
ébullition à cause d'un article qui est
paru dans le monde alors pourtant quand
on regarde la une du monde vous allez
voir il y a pas franchement de quoi
s'exciter borne appelle à l'apaisement
avec des guillemets pour bien montrer
que c'est elle qui l'a dit tu parles
d'un scoop elle a donné une interview il
y a 15 jours à l'AFP avec exactement les
mêmes propos qui ont été repris dans
toute la presse alors pourquoi 15 jours
plus tard le mot apaisement d'un coup à
folle tout le monde
bon ça c'est
la page 8 qui a la réponse c'est parce
qu'il y a des fautes d'avoir un scoop en
fait le monde a réussi à créer une
polémique parce que dans le titre vous
voyez il est dit que si elle parle
d'apaisement aujourd'hui c'est dans
l'intention de se démarquer de Macron
bon alors est-ce que c'est vraiment le
cas quand on lit l'article la large
journaliste de ne pas de détails sur les
circonstances de cette rencontre on
pourrait presque imaginer que ils
avaient de borne ayant un peu le blues à
fait venir ce grand journal du soir si
respecter chez elle pour se confier
alors que pas du tout c'est Matignon qui
a juste organisé des rencontres avec la
presse il y a des deux groupes de
journalistes un premier le matin donc il
y avait le monde RTL d'autres un
deuxième groupe l'après-midi il y a le
Parisien et elle s'est fait et ben oui
on y était et on doit vous dire que nous
on a pas eu le sentiment que l'intention
de la programmée Nice c'était de se
démarquer du président en tout cas
c'était pas le message qu'elle voulait
envoyer mais vous savez ce que c'est ou
peut-être pas mais une première ministre
qui plaide l'apaisement ça n'intéresse
pas grand monde sauf sauf sauf si elle
plaide l'apaisement pour marquer ces
différents avec le président alors là
oui là c'est breaking news et d'ailleurs
regardez qui est le premier sur l'info
comme d'habitude BFM à 8h05 la
journaliste qui est là et qui nous
explique que la première ministre a pris
très clairement ses distances avec le
chef de l'État ça c'est 8h05 à 10h45 bah
obligé publié le démenti d'Élisabeth ban
qui dit exactement le contraire donc je
vous rappelle ce que disait Pierre
Lazareff une information et un démenti
ça fait deux informations on écoute vous
savez on échange régulièrement avec le
président de la République et je pense
qu'on partage la même analyse il y a
besoin d'apaisement dans notre pays
c'est ce que j'ai dit dès le départ et
il y a besoin d'apporter des réponses
rapides et on est parfaitement aligné
sur ce sujet vous savez vous avez
peut-être remarqué à quel point les
journalistes sont parfois corporatrices
et moi forcément je me sens un peu
solidaire de mes collègues mais
franchement imaginez si pardon Elizabeth
Bank convoque l'ensemble de la presse à
Matignon pour exposer ses différents
avec Macron pourquoi le lendemain il
dirait exactement le contraire ça veut
dire qu'elle est beaucoup beaucoup plus
fatiguée que ce qu'on imagine bon moi
j'y crois pas trop en tout cas il y en a
un qui surf bon avec gourmandise on va
dire sur cette petite polémique c'est
Laurent Berger ce matin sur BFM
oui je suis d'accord sur le fait que il
faut de l'apaisement c'était mes mots il
y a encore quelques heures sur sur des
antennes mais effectivement c'est autre
chose que de mettre un peu de l'huile
sur le feu que de parler d'apaisement et
de respect entre les différents acteurs
de cette période alors y a-t-il vraiment
de l'eau dans le gaz entre l'Elysée et
Matillon si on cherche un peu la petite
bête on peut éventuellement trouver
quelque chose dire que l'autre jour à
13h le président lui a donné comme
mission Isabelle borne de bâtir une
majorité élargie oral dit non moi je
pense qu'il faut des majorités textes
par textes enfin si on lit bien elle dit
texte par Tex il n'y a pas d'autres
alternatives mais à court terme donc
elle l'exclut pas non plus l'hypothèse
de la majorité et l'argile mais bon là
j'ai un petit peu dégonflé la polémique
rassurez-vous il y a quand même matière
à débattre parce que même si Elisabeth
borne n'était parfaitement alignée sur
le président Macron c'est pas pour
autant qu'elle sera encore là dans 15
jours à Matignon c'est sûr merci
beaucoup Stéphane pour ce pour ce billet
piquant à souhait comme comme chaque
soir Elsa puisqu’elle CP était présent à
ce deuxième rendez-vous il y en a eu
deux à Matignon d'abord pourquoi elle
s'exprime comme ça de façon un peu
coulisse sachant qu'elle autorise on
voit dans les articles à ce que certains
de ces propos soient reprises ça veut
dire qu'elle veut rester là où elle est
bah avant tout elle fait le passé le
message qu'elle est au travail qu'elle
est pas usée et qu'elle fait campagne
pour rester à son poste effectivement
après on le voit même si elle a pas
forcément voulu se démarquer du
président de la République c'est quand
même la lecture qui en effet quand on
compare les vocabulaires elle l'a
rappelé apaisement c'est un mot qu'elle
a redit plusieurs fois au journaliste ça
tranche quand même avec la musique du
président de la République qui est lui
est beaucoup plus dans un bras de fer
depuis la Chine avec les syndicats donc
malgré tout on voit qu'il y a une nuance
dans le discours même si à la fin elle
la redit ils sont alignés ils pensent la
même chose c'est peut-être un petit peu
plus compliqué que ça et Nathalie Sego
il y a deux registres sémantiques
l'apaisement ne pas brusquer elle dit
même respecter une période de
convalescence les mots sont importants
la convalescence ça prend le temps pour
guérir de cette crise des retraites ne
pas humilier les syndicats c'est un jeu
de quoi good COP Badcock ou c'est plus
compliqué je crois pas que ce soit
totalement que ce soit une scène écrite
à l'avance entre les deux têtes de
l'exécutif au contraire je crois que ça
vient juste après c'est à dire que dans
le calendrier c'est pour ça que ça prend
l'ampleur que que décrivait ses fans
lakowski c'est que ça vient juste après
un échange d'une violence assez rare
entre Emmanuel Macron et Laurent Berger
sur la crise démocratique Macron depuis
la Chine en plus c'est à dire qu'il
parle à l'étranger de la politique
intérieure française il se cache au
départ derrière le Off en disant donc
les premières dépêches qui sortent c'est
l'entourage ensuite Laurent Berger dit
soyons pas dupe c'est on sait tous que
c'est parce que tout le monde reconnaît
les mots
la violence verbale d'Emmanuel Macron on
sait que c'est pas son entourage qui
parle comme ça et donc dit non il y a
pas de crise démocratique on peut
contrairement à ce que vient de dire
Laurent Berger en sortant de Matignon et
la CFD il continue à attaquer la CFDT
qui n'a pas proposé de projet sur les
soins pour comme alternative au 64 ans
donc tout ça vient en fait c'est off qui
sont
si j'ai bien retracé le parcours
convoqué par Elisabeth borne en début de
semaine ils arrivent après une séquence
dans un contexte particulier ils
arrivent dans ce contexte là du coup
quand elle dit l'apaisement il faut
apaiser ça prend une autre valeur que si
elle l'avait dit le lundi le mardi ça
prend un relief particulier
notamment avec Laurent Berger pourquoi
on a l'impression que il veut tendre
encore plus la situation avec ce niveau
de tension sur les retraites qu'on
connaît déjà
parce que alors fondamentalement il
manque Emmanuel Macron il manque de
rondeurs de il a pas à cette traîne là
il l'a jamais eu on voit pas très bien
pourquoi il l'aurait aujourd'hui il est
exacte
ce temps qui n'en finit pas dans
l'attente de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel par le blocage les
manifestations le ton de Laurent Berger
lui il voit qu'est-ce qu'il voit lui que
les manifestations la mobilisation
recule que le taux de grévise recule que
le cheminement démocratique comme il dit
s'est déroulé de son point de vue tout à
fait normalement et qu'on vient encore
lui chercher qu'on vient encore exiger
de lui une pause ou je ne sais quoi et
ça l'insupporte parce que lui il
considère qu'il a gagné que que il y a
pas eu qu'il est un démocrate qu'il est
pas un dictateur qu'il a respecté la
légalité constitutionnelle et que donc
il y a aucune raison et que la
mobilisation elle-même elle est
inférieure à la mobilisation sur de la
réforme en 95 par exemple je précise
quand même que la première ministre
elle-même considère que Laurent Berger
n'est pas dans son rôle à parler de
crise démocratique crise sociale oui
comme syndicaliste mais pas crise
démocratique le cheminement démocratique
les institutions étaient respectées et
ça c'est vrai quelque soit les
verbatimes repris dans les papiers du
jour Stéphane zumsteg les Français
imputent la responsabilité cette crise
davantage à Manuel Macron ou à Elizabeth
borne mais bien plus à Emmanuel Macron
que Elisabeth borne les Français ne sont
pas vus puissent très bien que ça se
réforme elle a été voulue par le
président de la République ça fait ça
fait pas depuis le mois de janvier qui
n'ont pas et on parle depuis des années
rappelez-vous dans le cadre de la
campagne pour sa réélection se poser la
question de savoir s'il faudrait passer
sa réforme ce qui tenterait de la faire
passer avant ou après sa réélection ça
fait des mois si ce n'est des années que
ça dure et les Français dès le début ont
imputé à Emmanuel Macron la
responsabilité
de ce qui s'est passé et dont on a
popularité c'est pour ça que j'entends
souvent dire que Elizabeth borne est un
fusible où serait un fusible mais c'est
pas un fusible un fusible ça protège et
à le moment il Elisabeth borne n'a plus
protéger le président de la République
parce que dès le début c'était la
réforme de Macron pour les Français
22% d'opinion favorables 25% pour
Emmanuel Macron 22 pour Elizabeth borne
selon vos confrères de l'Institut élab
plus un populaire que Nicolas Sarkozy un
an après encore plus une populaire que
Nicolas Sarkozy j'ai envie de dire et
quand on voit dans le détail ce qui est
vraiment grave pour lui c'est le taux de
personnes qui sont véritablement hostile
c'est à dire les gens qui sont
totalement défavorable totalement
opposés totalement hostile à sa
politique sont des niveaux très élevés
il y a plus d'un tiers des Français qui
rejettent totalement sa politique quand
on va dans le détail aussi on voit que
même si le niveau de d'opposition projet
est resté remarquablement stable durant
des semaines durant des mois on voit
également que ce qu'il faisait le cœur
électoral de la macronie des cadres
supérieurs des retraités bien ces
gens-là petit à petit on décrochait sont
moins hostiles que d'autres types de
français de françaises au projet de
réforme mais malgré tout il y a plus au
début 80% de du cœur de la macronie
favorable à ce projet certes ça restait
une minorité de français mais ça tenait
les milieux aisés des grandes
agglomérations les cadres supérieurs
étaient favorables les retraités et
favorables aujourd'hui sont beaucoup
plus partagés tout le monde doute il y a
un vrai doute y compris l'opposition
le soutien à l'opposition de la réforme
tient dans le temps vraiment il tient
dans le temps et
dans un premier temps de tir des
Français a été opposées aux modalités de
la réforme aux 64 ans ou 40 ou 43 ans de
cotisations aujourd'hui c'est bien plus
grave pour l'exécutif ils sont opposés à
la méthode de 49.3 la censure toutes ces
choses-là le passage en force ou la
tentative de passage en force par
l'exécutif a été extrêmement en a
rajouté une couche on était contre la
réforme mais maintenant on trouve on
juge inacceptable s'il fallait
simplifier les choses inacceptables la
posture et l'attitude d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est bien ça son problème il est pris
dans une masse aujourd'hui on va parler
des voix de sortie possibles du Conseil
constitutionnel Benjamin Morel mais tout
à l'heure Stéphane zoumsteg dit elle
n'est pas du tout un fusible parce
qu'elle ne protège pas le président la
cinquième public c'est ça l'idée le
Premier ministre protège le président de
la République on a eu des grands couples
comme ça avec des clashs souviens de
Fillon Sarkozy Valls Hollande on savait
que c'était difficile là on n'est pas
dans ce cas de figure non on n'est pas
dans ce cas de figure et puis il faut
pas non plus idéaliser entre guillemets
le fusible ou le paratonnerre comme
étant Premier ministre si vous regardez
je parle sur le contrôle de Stéphane
sauceg mais si vous regardez les
premiers ministres qui ont été remerciés
en cours de mandat ça a conduit à la
nommation d'un nouveau Premier ministre
qui pouvait être populaire mais ça peut
à rétabli la courbe de popularité du
président de la République le fusible il
n'existe pas réellement c'est une
théorie qui vient qui existe à partir de
1963 1963 vous avez des grèves massives
des grèves des mineurs et de Gaulle
tombent dans les sondages de 10 points
et là à ce moment-là il se dit et ben à
partir de maintenant il y a une forme de
disjonction des rôles Pompidou va
s'occuper au moins en in deux
l'économique et du social et moi je
m'occupe des affaires du monde on a
comme ça un dispatche des rôles qui
permet un petit peu de protéger le
président mais en aucun cas le fusible
n'est fondamentalement efficace et là il
est doublement transparent ce fusible il
est transparent parce que évidemment
depuis le début du quinquennat on a une
personnalisation dans les mains du
Président de la République qui fait que
le premier ministre est bien va avoir un
rôle perçu comme étant moins et qui plus
est comme ça bien été dit on a ici une
réforme qui est inhérente à la
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron donc et
c'est ça qui d'une certaine façon
cruelle dans cette interview parce que
cette interview quoi qui est voulu dire
Elizabeth borne elle met en avant de
problèmes aujourd'hui d'Emmanuel Macron
le rapport au syndicat et l'absence de
cap pour la suite si aujourd'hui est des
points qui vont être des points diriment
pour lui et qui même si ils ne sont pas
formulés comme étant une marque de
distance et bien des moments où ils sont
présents sont quand même désécratinures
vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron et ça par
définition et bah ces problématique on
va venir sur le cap dans un instant un
petit mot à ce stade des débats Eric
Emmanuel elle veut pas jouer les
bouquets mystères de la crise des
retraites c'est un peu ça qu'on comprend
non seulement elle n'est pas un fusible
mais je crois
que la différence avec beaucoup de
Premier ministre c'est qu'elle n'a pas
d'autres raisons d'être politique que
d'avoir été nommé là c'est-à-dire elle a
pas sa volonté de carrière comme pouvait
avoir tout d'un coup un Chirac par
rapport à Giscard d'Estaing etc c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas une politique qui
pense à son avenir après au sein du
monde politique donc elle est plus
serviteur de l'État une technocrate une
technocrate elle est au service de
Macron Macron Macron la mise là donc
elle est encore moins fusible que que
ils n'ont jamais été mais elle est
encore moins alors on va revenir quand
même sur c'est presque 10 mois dans
presque 11 mois
Elisabeth borne à Matignon un style une
façon de faire vis-à-vis des députés
également regarder c'est un sujet de
Marco poli
le scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale le scrutin va
être ouvert pour démission la nupesse
réclame à l'unisson le départ
d'Elizabeth borne 20 mars 2023 la motion
de censure est rejetée de justesse à
nevoit près seulement le gouvernement et
la première ministre restent en place
mais pour combien de temps une première
ministre qui n'a négativité ni pouvoir
pour pouvoir continuer son action et qui
doit évidemment démissionner elle a
annoncé elle-même qu'elle accepté d'être
le fusible banco qu'elle saute Elisabeth
borne a Matignon c'était pourtant le
choix de la stabilité dans le changement
16 mai 2022 pour la deuxième fois sous
la Cinquième République une femme
devient première ministre 31 ans après
Edith Cresson je voudrais dédier cette
nomination à toutes les petites filles
en leur disant allez au bout de vos
rêves symboliquement Elizabeth borna
dépassé lundi la longévité d'Edith
Cresson à Matignon de femmes confrontées
aux mêmes difficultés l'absence de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
alors dès son arrivée la première
ministre théorise une méthode je veux
qu'ensemble nous redonnions un sens et
une vertu aux mots compromis le
compromis texte par textes une méthode
aux résultats mitigé pour une première
ministre très vite surnommée madame 49.3
a dit reprise elle l'actionnera cette
arme constitutionnelle sur le budget de
l'État et sur celui de la sécurité
sociale les oppositions lui reprochent
un manque de dialogue la chef du
gouvernement les prend au mot
[Applaudissements]
son plus grand chantier l'impopulaire
réforme des retraites qui résonnent
comme un échec Intex d'abord présenté
comme juste et équilibré le gouvernement
parlera finalement d'une réforme
obligatoire pour des raisons budgétaires
on ne peut pas faire de Paris sur
l'avenir de nos retraites cette réforme
est nécessaire après 11 journées de
mobilisation sociale et à quelques jours
de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel Elisabeth borne n'a
toujours pas cédé
[Musique]
voilà on n'a pas toujours pas cédé elle
est soutenue dans la majorité encore
aujourd'hui elle a des alliés elle a des
alliés dans la majorité ensuite il y en
a clairement qui considère que sa
méthode a été un échec elle devait
trouver une majorité sur cette réforme
des retraites elle avait même demandé un
peu plus de temps pour le faire alors
qu'on sait qu'Emmanuel Macron plaidait
plus pour une solution rapide donc ça il
y a clairement des gens qui réclament
son départ ensuite il y a des gens qui
disent de toute façon son départ même si
il est quasiment inévitable ne changera
pas tant qu'on n'a pas une nouvelle
histoire à raconter un nouveau cap et
puis qui mettre à la place et puis
d'autres gens la soutiennent vraiment
mais surtout parce qu'ils ont peur de du
Premier ministre est-ce qu'on va mettre
un premier ministre de droite à la place
d'Elizabeth borne donc elle reste elle
est soutenue en fait parmi les députés
c'est pas le cas borne c'est même plus
grave que ça c'est j'ai envie de dire
c'est on la change très bien mais pour
faire quoi pour dire quoi pour mettre
qui voilà alors justement d'ailleurs
Stanislas Guérini lui il la soutient
publiquement vous explique le ministre
de la Fonction publique notre intérêt
est désormais de faire bloc le
redémarrage du quinquennat doit se faire
pas à pas et elle est la mieux placée
pour cela si ça redémarre pas à pas ça
veut dire qu'on sait pas très bien où on
va et on change rien c'est ça Nathalie
segun c'est ce qui inquiète la majorité
et ce qui inquiète les ministres aussi
là aujourd'hui ils sont tous en
suspension et
évidemment qui est manuel Macron prend
mal les propos d'Elisabeth borne sur le
cap parce que il sait que ça lui
restait à lui tout le monde toute la
majorité attend que ça sorte ils ont ils
ont tous l'habitude de je vous interroge
juste pour redonner les propos sur le
cap pour qu'on arrive à suivre elle dit
très clairement dans le monde avant de
trouver des alliés il faut redonner du
sens à notre action donner du souffle à
ce qu'on veut faire je ne suis pas là
pour administrer le pays sous-entendu le
cap n'est pas fixé pour le moment c'est
au président de le faire sans cap on est
bloqué donc c'est pas de ma faute oui
alors l'Élysée ce à quoi l'Elysée fait
répondre le cap il a été fixé le 22 mars
sur TF1 et France 2 quand j'ai dit comme
président a dit il faut élargir trouver
une majorité élargie
alors que tout le monde sait que c'est
impossible la mission impossible et que
c'est pas ça un cap un cap c'est une
vision c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on met en avant qu'elle
comment comment on continue de la loi
travail de l'école tout ça c'est pas le
cap elle dit on peut pas faire on peut
pas poursuivre le quinquennat après les
retraites sur la fin de vie et les EHPAD
c'est pas après avoir fait les retraites
il faut quand même quelque chose qui qui
mobilise le pays qui soit un peu plus
optimiste qui qui c'est pas possible de
faire les quatre ans qui restent là
dessus alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer
qui réfléchit l'avocat pense alors elle
est psychoère manifestement réfléchie
avec le cabinet on a lu dans politique
osmétique il voyait Ismaël émelien mais
c'est ce sont des pures techniques l'un
des premiers stratèges de la campagne
des grands techno donc Emmanuel Macron
je vais vous montrer dans la majorité
que ça ne sortira pas de là moi mon
maudit il va préparer quelque chose
Macron va faire quelque chose va sortir
du bois mais personne ne sait ce qui
évidemment ce qu'il va faire ni quand
etc et surtout ce qui est ce qui est
frappant c'est que dans cette majorité
tout le monde attend toujours que ça
vienne d'en haut c'est toujours cette
toujours fonctionné comme ça donc cette
fois-ci encore on s'en remet au grand
chef on a tendance que la fumée blanche
sorte de l'Élysée et on sent un Emmanuel
Macron qui est à cours d'idée qui a
cours de qui n'a pas la vista qu'il
avait depuis le début de quinquennat
qu'il avait dans le premier quinquennat
clairement donc et qui ne peut pas
réinventer le grand débat possible gilet
jaune le CNR ça n'a pas marché les
conventions de la rénovation il a essayé
de surfer enfin il a essayé de dire
qu'il allait reprendre que la méthode
avait bien marché avec sur la fin de vie
et que donc il pouvait y avoir quelque
chose à un fil à tiré mais c'est pas ça
qui va redonner de l'élan
et un programme de gouvernement en fait
se souligne Elisabeth band c'est la
panne en fait de cette exécutif et qui
est d'abord celle d'Emmanuel Macron
Benjamin Morel la sortie potentielle ce
serait une censure formelle de du texte
qui remettrait à zéro au fond le
quinquennat en censurant la réforme des
retraites vous y croyez ou pas alors
c'est possible il y a trois scénarios le
plus improbable ce serait une
acceptation totale une non censure du
Conseil constitutionnel il y a
clairement des cavaliers sociaux donc il
y aura probablement des dispositions
censurées la plus probable c'est une
censure de certaines dispositions
cavaliers sociaux mais en réalité ça
remet pas en cause les 64 ans eux ils
sont constitutionnels du point de vue du
fond donc ça posera pas de souci si
jamais il y a une censure partielle et
en effet il peut y avoir une censure
globale parce que c'est pas vous que je
vais apprendre que la procédure sur
cette réforme elle a été plus ou moins
baroque et donc là il y a une marge
d'appréciation du conseil qui peut
censurer évidemment ça remettrait à zéro
les tensions sur la réforme des
retraites et sur des questions comme le
travail l'École etc syndicat pourrait
redevenir des partenaires parce que pour
l'instant et bien comme les syndicats ne
veulent discuter que des 64 ans vous
pouvez vouloir tourner la page mais ce
ne sera pas avec eux en revanche ce que
ça ne remettra probablement pas à zéro
c'est l'effet de décomposition de la
majorité parlementaire or il faut bien
voir que le Président de la République
les Français ont l'impression que le
président a tous les pouvoirs mais le
président ont droit à très peu de
pouvoir il a des pouvoirs d'exception il
n'a de pouvoir que parce qu'il tient une
majorité pléthorique et discipliné cette
majorité elle est relative elle n'est
pas disciplinée l'intergroupe ensemble
et aujourd'hui extrêmement évanescent et
qui plus est les alliés potentiels qui
ne peuvent être que LR sont des alliés
en carton patte ou parliez des dites
cresson tout à l'heure et bien Edith
Cresson comme Michel Rocard comme Pierre
Bérégovoy ils avaient derrière eux un
parti le Parti socialiste qui avait
certes une majorité relative et il y
avait des groupes le groupe communiste
et le groupe centriste et ses groupes là
quand il vous disait qu'il ne voterait
pas une notion de censure quand ils
acceptaient votre réforme il tenait
hors-là quand on passe de 65 à 64 ans
sur cette réforme c'est pour faire
plaisir à LR résultat au bout compte et
bien vous finissez avec un 49 à Alina 3
c'est une notion sensuelle qui passe
quasiment à neuf ou après donc en effet
il y a un problème alors l'état d'esprit
des troupes de la majorité à la fois
renaissances modem horizon est-ce qu'il
y a du désarroi face cette perte de
boussole manifeste il y a du désarroi
alors il y a vraiment des deux il y a
aussi le fait qu'il se rendent compte
que depuis cette l'article 49-3 et la
motion de censure mais il y a quand même
le texte sur les choses Olympiques qui a
été adopté le texte sur le nucléaire qui
a été adopté visiblement sur la fin de
vie il va y avoir une co-construction il
le rappelle Elisabeth borne elle a
utilisé beaucoup le 49-3 mais il y a
beaucoup de textes aussi qui ont été
adoptés un peu une fois grâce au
socialiste une autre fois grâce aux
républicain et donc de toute façon
effectivement il ne croit pas qu'on
puisse élargir la majorité mais sur ce
fonctionnement texte par texte il y a un
principe de réalité qu'il partage et
après comme disait très bien Nathalie
c'est vrai qu'ils sont on peut pas dire
on va travailler sur dire que le travail
l'école la santé l'écologie sont des
priorités c'est pas un cap ça tout dire
ça veut rien dire donc dans les députés
quand on les rencontre en ce moment bah
ils sont tous à la recherche d'une idée
d'une chose qui pourrait s'imposer et
parfois ça peut être des choses très
concrètes sur le logement des prêts pour
rénover des prêts à taux zéro pour
rénover les maisons des choses comme ça
mais c'est pas un cap non plus mais tout
le monde essaye d'avoir la bonne idée
qui pourrait essayer d'imprimer un peu
même s'ils ont bien conscience
qu'effectivement c'est à Emmanuel Macron
bien de réinventer une histoire de
raconter quelque chose et que ça eux
n'ont pas le pouvoir de le faire les
Français on arrive à les sonder sur
cette attente d'une forme de relance
d'une perspective est-ce qu'ils ont des
priorités j'imagine le pouvoir d'achat
la question des salaires une
préoccupation vous avez raison c'est le
pouvoir d'achat mais c'est une
préoccupation c'est pas une priorité
contenue de ce qui s'est fait de ce qui
s'est passé depuis la fin du mois de
janvier la relation entre les Français
et le pouvoir en place est extrêmement
abîmé donc et c'est bien le problème
d'Emmanuel Macron et donc quelque part
par ricochet de sa première ministre
c'est que quoi qu'ils disent quoi qu'il
fasse il est dans une nasse il est dans
un étau et tout ce qu'il dit totalement
inaudible
les Français sur la suite sur le sursaut
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on demande
dissolution remaniement on teste des
personnalités pour la remplacer à
Matignon comment on arrive à savoir les
attentes c'est la suite c'est la suite
dans deux jours dans 3 jours c'est quel
sera le degré de mobilisation jeudi
prochain que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est ça le drame le
chemin de croix de ce gouvernement
depuis fin janvier c'est que quasiment
tous les jours il se passe quelque chose
une journée de mobilisation il y a le
Conseil constitutionnel dont on attend
la décision il y a visiblement des
signes on en parle aujourd'hui de
dissension au sein de l'exécutif ce qui
laissera des traces c'est dramatique ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui ça prouve bien
les gens sont fondamentalement opposés à
cette réforme et dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose dès qu'il y a la moindre
anicroche d'acclidia la même la moindre
interprétation de langage ou d'absence
de cap pour reprendre ce que vous venez
de dire les Français se mettent à dire
mais finalement même eux n'y croient
plus donc pour répondre à votre question
au-delà de ça nous ce qu'ils veulent
avant tout c'est le retrait retrait dont
il ne croyait dont il ne croyait qu'ils
dont il ne croyait pas possible
de la résignation c'était plus quelque
part un pronostic ils étaient contre
c'était le pronostic que Macron comme
d'habitude passerait en force il n'a pas
pu véritablement passer en force puisque
puisque la contestation est toujours là
c'est ça ce que les Français pensent
depuis quelques pas quelques jours mais
quelques semaines c'est que finalement
peut-être qu'on peut tordre le bras à ce
président et à ce gouvernement ce qui
n'était absolument pas le cas en janvier
et en février et face au blocage actuel
du centre le président est perdu alors
est-ce qu'il est vraiment perdu ou pas
je n'en sais rien mais en tout cas on
voit monter ce sentiment auprès des
Français on l'a eu quelque part on est
en train de le coincer on est en train
de le bloquer et donc
je parle évidemment des deux tiers de
français voir des 70% de Français qui
sont aussi au projet de réforme et donc
peut-être qu'il est possible de le faire
rendre de lui faire grande regorge et de
lui faire retirer ce projet et c'est ça
qui est c'est ça qui est nouveau de plus
en plus de gens sont convaincus que
c'est possible soit par des voies
constitutionnelles le légal le Conseil
constitutionnel soit par la rue soit par
des voies politiques s'il y avait des
solutions et c'est ça le vrai problème
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui un
président dans la NAF un pays bloqué
dont on voit pas forcément le la suite
la sortie de crise ça vous désole ça
vous angoisse
c'est que je trouve que la retraite ça
concerne toutes les injustices de la vie
donc faire une réforme des retraites
c'est ces traités presque tout de
l'existence des gens donc c'est
forcément un sujet extrêmement délicat
et ça a été traité sans aucune empathie
ça a été balancé comme ça donner d'abord
comme juste alors que
on ne corrige pas les injustices de
l'existence au contraire on les accentue
à ce moment-là de la vie et puis
après avoir
d'après cette prétention de justesse et
de justice on a dit bah non c'est
surtout comptable etc mais c'est à
bérant d'être aussi nul excusez-moi
d'empathie on retrouve même chez ceux
qui soutiennent Elisabeth borne disent
bon pour l'empathie on repassera
évidemment puisque à tous les moments
sur chacune de ces expressions
télévisées elle en a quand même
cruellement manqué
Nathalie se gode pour terminer on a
compris que ça sera peut-être texte par
textes en tout cas pas à pas dans les le
court terme les semaines à venir
puisqu'on ne trouve pas de majorité les
LR ne sont plus fiables à gauche non
plus hein casser la nupette avec les
socialistes bon avec les syndicats la
première ministre seront très optimistes
elle estime qu'ils ne pourront pas
laisser la chaise vide elle a dit ça
comme ça pour les prochains textes
notamment sur la pénibilité est-ce que
ces crédible est-ce qu'il pourrait
revenir à la table des négociations si
le Conseil Conseil constitutionnel
valide le texte elle elle l'a toujours
considéré effectivement qu'elle avait un
lien particulier avec Laurent Berger
avec la CFDT notamment et qu'elle
arriverait toujours à elle pleine elle
le met beaucoup en avant pour pour dire
à Macron il faut que je reste même après
la réforme des retraites parce que c'est
moi qui vais réussir à renouer le fil on
y a une animosité réelle entre Laurent
Berger Emmanuel Macron elle elle pense
en revanche qu'elle peut y arriver mais
elle peut y arriver avec avec quoi avec
des des un texte sur le travail et qui
est la grande le grand échec c'est
d'avoir mis cette réforme des retraites
avant de faire avant de parler du
travail et de faire un grand débat sur
le travail donc elle elle pense pouvoir
y arriver sur effectivement renouer le
lien avec eux sur des sujets c'est pour
les sons de leur de leur domaine de
compétences des semaines les semaines
qui viennent à court et moyen terme à
l'été elle sera remplacée qui pour la
remplacer vous qui êtes bien informé
elles aiment mon bingava Nathalie segun
il y a des noms qui circulent de
Catherine Vautrin aujourd'hui qui on le
savait elle a failli être première
ministre elle est interviewée
aujourd'hui c'est ça tombe à point
nommer et non il y a des noms qui
reviennent Gérald Darmanin Bruno Le
Maire mais
on sait aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron cherche
toujours un peu la surprise c'est des
noms qui reviennent à chaque fois qu'on
parle d'un remaniement donc ce qui va
essayer de chercher la surprise
peut-être Nathalie sogone moi ces
derniers jours c'est les dernières
heures même c'est d'entendre des
macronistes dire ah là là si on avait
gardé Castex pour faire cette réforme
des retraites j'encaisse il y a une
nostalgie de Castex sous l'angle lui
aurait su parler au syndicat aurait eu
la rondeur aurait su avoir aller
chercher les LR les quand on en est à
faire le match c'est qu'il y a un site
préféré
bon on va s'arrêter là vous l'avez
compris c'était un peu un débat
d'attente un débat de suspension mais en
Suisse feuilleton des retraites voilà
quasi quotidiennement sur LCP merci
d'être venu débattre avec nous vous
restez avec moi Éric-Emmanuel Schmitt
dans une dizaine de minutes elle est
partie pris de nos affranchis vous les
voyez ils sont trois ce soir à faire
c'est le mot qui a choisi marriette
darrigan du voyage de faire d'Emmanuel
Macron en Chine à l'affaire Schiappa
dans Playboy c'est tout un programme
Bertrand Perrier lui se désole ce soir
de l'annulation du concert de Bilal
Hassani menacé par les intégristes et
puis Bourbon express avec tibohenoc qui
va nous raconter ce soir le retour
soumis au vote d'Adrien Catena dans le
groupe des insoumis mais d'abord on va
partir à Jérusalem avec vous
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt incroyable
pèlerinage en Terre sainte que vous
propose le pape François en personne
c'est l'histoire d'un carnet de voyage
qui nous est présenté dans l'invitation
d'Hélène Bonduelle et on en parle tous
les deux juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt c'est pour évoquer
votre dernier défi littéraire le défi de
Jérusalem une expérience de foi qui
aurait pu ne jamais arriver et qui
commence par un coup de fil surprise du
Vatican nous aimerions beaucoup vous
envoyer en Terre sainte vous visiteriez
les lieux feriez des rencontres et
peut-être en reviendriez vous avec un
livre un journal de votre voyage qu'en
pensez-vous
l'esprit ne se nourrit pas de pierre de
sentier de bâtiment écrivez-vous dès les
premières pages
[Musique]
est-ce que ma vie spirituelle allait
être changée par mes pieds qui allait
traverser cette cette terre et ben oui
vous acceptez donc ce carnet de voyage
votre 34e ouvrage Eric Emmanuel Schmitt
romancier dramaturge comédien philosophe
vous êtes traduit en 48 langues vos
récits traversent le monde écrire c'est
explorer explorer le monde c'est être
aventurier c'est fouiller la complexité
humaine partir dans une autre époque
partir sur un autre espace le défi de
Jérusalem un prolongement de votre
expérience mystique aux portes du Sahara
il y a 30 ans et que vous décriviez dans
la nuit de feu cette fois vous prenez le
lecteur par la main vous l'emmenez à
travers la ville et ces lieux saints ces
marchands de Bon Dieu riz qui vous
exaspèrent parfois vous l'emmenez
surtout sur les traces de votre
cheminement spirituel
quand on est à Jérusalem Dieu nous dit
non pas entendez-moi mais entendez-vous
et comme une bénédiction de celui qui
vous avait invité à ce voyage spirituel
le livre se termine avec une postface du
pape François alors
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt après ce voyage en
Terre sainte nous avons une question
pour vous vous l'enfant à l'éducation
athée sortez-vous indemne de cette
nouvelle nuit de feu
réponse Eric Emmanuel Schmitt
je suis revenu complètement changé de
mon christianisme il était nourri dans
la solitude dans la lecture des
évangiles c'était une fois farouche
indépendante je ne rejoignais jamais les
autres et
en arrivant Jérusalem il s'est passé
deux choses comme j'ai éprouvé
d'immenses émotions à certains endroits
et bien mon christianisme est devenu
charnel comme si tout d'un coup mon
corps éprouvait ce que mon esprit ne
peut pas comprendre parce que c'est
incompréhensible la base du
christianisme et puis aussi la deuxième
conséquence c'est que puisque j'ai
rejoint un pèlerinage j'ai découvert ce
qui était partagé sa foi avec les autres
la force des rites la nécessité des
rites des rendez-vous réguliers qui vous
oblige à vous recentrer alors que la vie
disperse pulvérise
le bienfait de même de la prière répétée
comme si j'avais pris une colonne
vertébrale oui ça commence par un appel
et qu'elle appelle il émane directement
du Vatican qui vous demande d'aller en
Terre Sainte avec l'idée de revenir avec
un carnet de voyage impossible de
refuser ou vous avez comme un peu édité
j'ai pas hésité du tout il y a une
disponibilité qui s'est ouverte
immédiatement en moi je me suis bah
voilà pourquoi je ne suis pas encore
allé toutes mes tentatives de voyage ont
raté
c'est parce que ça devait être comme ça
mais vous aviez quand même un peu
d'appréhension celle de ne rien éprouver
celle de ne pas au fond rencontrer ce
qui vous attendait c'est la peur de tout
pèlerin puis le pèlerin contemporain il
est pas comme le pèlerin des du passé
nos ancêtres qui partaient sans aucune
image nous on est déjà plein d'images il
y a plus d'inconnues pour nous quand on
part en voyage donc il y avait des
clichés qui qui encombraient ma vue et
surtout cette grande peur que vous
évoquez celle de ne rien sentir de juste
faire un voyage touristique ou
archéologique alors c'est quoi le
défiusalem exactement moi je crois que
Jérusalem c'est un lieu absolument
unique dans l'histoire du monde parce
que c'est d'abord un lieu où Dieu a dit
entendez moi puisque les trois
monothéisme se sont fondés là le
judaïsme avec ces deux temples tous les
deux détruits à Jérusalem cette branche
de judaïsme qui est le christianisme qui
qui s'accomplit à Jérusalem en suite et
puis
ces points importants aussi de l'islam
puisque le rocher ou Abraham a failli tu
es Ismaël et non pas Isaac et ensuite
les voyages de Mahomet ont pensé etc on
est fratricide si on n'est pas fraternel
et si l'on oublie le père expliquez-nous
ça alors le père je dirais il a parlé
là-bas il a fait il a fondé les
monothéisme mais après les hommes ont
oublié parce que je pense que le propre
du fratricide
c'est d'oublier qu'il y a un père au
dessus
on est fraternel quand on qu'on a une
origine et qu'on doit quelque chose à
cette origine et qu'on se reconnaît dans
cette origine c'est Dieu c'est ce qui
nous dépasse c'est une forme de tiers
qui n'est pas soit pour nous c'est
l'origine mais c'est le passé aussi
penser qu'on est à l'origine de soi-même
et qu'on commence tout c'est totalement
faux il faut se sentir dans une
filiation historique ça peut être même
l'origine ça peut être la République ce
qui est assez reconnaître une
transcendance reconnaître une
transcendance d'ailleurs vous avez
longtemps bravé intellectuellement le
christianisme qui vous avait quelque
part rencontrer ça a été un long chemin
oui
d'abord parce que j'ai rencontré la foi
en Dieu avant de devenir chrétien ce que
j'avais vécu dans le désert que je
racontais dans la nuit
c'est une expérience spirituelle c'est
une extase mystique ce n'est pas une
expérience religieuse du tout et fort
heureusement parce qu'elle m'a ouvert
cette expérience à toutes les religions
je me suis trouvé des frères et des
sœurs en mysticisme dans tous les lieux
de la terre à toutes les époques du
monde dans toutes les religions du monde
et la rencontre du christianisme et vous
dites même que des trois monothéistes le
christianisme est le plus grand défi
pour la raison avec cette idée d'un
homme Dieu c'est fou c'est impensable
homme Dieu impensable vous le philosophe
et puis la notion principale du
christianisme c'est l'amour comparé avec
le judaïsme c'est le respect on peut
vraiment rationnellement défendre la
nécessité du respect
la notion principale de l'islam c'est
l'obéissance on peut aussi avec des
arguments rationnels appuyer
la nécessité d'obéir mais l'amour c'est
l'échappement total à la raison c'est
pas des victimes l'amour c'est de la
folie c'est un peu aimer son ennemi et
justement la séduction pour moi du
christianisme c'est le défi c'est-à-dire
le défi à la raison de dire à la raison
tu ne suffis pas une vie doit se
débarrasser de l'intérêt du calcul pour
s'offrir à cette valeur irradiante de
l'amour ce que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant aussi c'est que vous
racontez aussi tout le business de la
religion vous arrivez au Saint-Sépulcre
il y a une file d'attente il y a une
ambiance un peu de parc d'attraction et
vous vous dites au fond ça ne peut pas
se passer parce qu'il y a trop au fond
de poids de tout ce de tout ce tourisme
de tout ce business et ça se produit
notamment quelque chose se produit c'est
ça c'est un moment je suis le plus
voltairien le plus agacé par tout ce qui
m'entoure vous savez où l'autre je ne
veux pas le reconnaître comme mon miroir
je me reconnais pas dans les gens qui
sont autour de moi j'ai envie de partir
et donc machinalement je suis une fille
machinalement je comprends qu'il faut
s'agenouiller là etc etc et au moment où
je le fais là je suis très versé par
quoi par quelles sensations
par le sentiment d'une présence mais
sensorielle l'odeur d'un corps la
chaleur quand on est près d'un corps il
y a une chaleur et c'est censé être
l'endroit où est mort
Jésus il y a 2000 ans et puis un regard
sur moi un regard qui m'oblige à moi je
résiste je cherche rationnellement d'où
vient vous fuyez d'ailleurs dans un
premier temps et après je m'enfuis et
puis je suis j'ai l'impression d'avoir
subi une violence
l'éruption de quelque chose et puis
après évidemment je tombe en larmes et
je remercie
il y a aussi des choses qui vous
déçoivent un peu des étonnements sur ce
chemin entre pas Jérusalem et Nazareth
par exemple l'église vous vous semble
moins belle que ce que vous auriez pu
imaginer vous écrivez l'unique berceau
de l'extraordinaire à Nazaret et
l'ordinaire c'est ça aussi la Terre
Sainte c'est ça et en plus on se balade
de lieu incertains en lieu douteux parce
que les attributions des moments de
l'Évangile à certains endroits sont
vraiment très très suspects et puis
d'ailleurs selon qu'on est catholique
orthodoxe on va pas dans la même grotte
pour la négociation de Marie etc donc au
bout d'un temps on se comprend que le
voyage on le fait avec les pieds certes
mais on le fait surtout avec l'esprit
c'est-à-dire que les lieux sont une
occasion ils sont pas le but du voyage
ils sont l'occasion de la méditation il
y a aussi évidemment de la violence de
l'intolérance et à la haine aussi entre
les communautés à Jérusalem on va parler
intéressant dans un instant mais vous
l'avez ressenti ça aussi les laïcs par
exemple on fuit Jérusalem il n'y a plus
que les religieux qui se sont mal
tolérées vous en avez parlé avec les
gens que vous avez tout le temps tout le
temps et puis de tous les côtés
non
en fait la remarque que je me suis fait
parce que on sent tellement
d'agressivité de gens qui ne se
regardent pas et vous savez
l'indifférence c'est une des premières
formes de la violence ne pas reconnaître
l'existence de l'autre en refusant même
de le regarder dans les yeux et ça c'est
constant à Jérusalem quand il n'y a pas
des attitudes carrément agressives mais
au quotidien c'est au minimum
l'indifférence ce qui est aussi une
forme de mur le face-à-face et et moi ce
que je me disais c'est au fond ce qui
m'étonne c'est que ça me pète pas plus
alors vous les avez vu ces images
Eric Emmanuel schmiton va les revoir
celle de la mosquée alaxa à Jérusalem
c'était dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi
la police israélienne étant très pour
d'après elle déloger des Palestiniens
équipés de feu d'artifice ou de Pierre
affrontement violent qui ont eu lieu et
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont été
arrêtées
on est on est dans un lieu saint comment
vous réagissez
justement que on délimite pas le sacré
et que contient pas compte du sacré est
une chose qui qui me choque mais ce que
je vois surtout c'est que la solution
n'est ni militaire ni politique et
parfois je pense qu'il y a des solutions
qui sont spirituelles je suis désolé ça
peut paraître extrêmement naïve mais
justement quand on est comme ça dans un
moment de tension en Israël très fort
avec une collection d'extrême droite qui
veut réformer la justice avec Benyamin
Netanya ou des manifestations très dures
contre lui le ciel et la terre disent la
même chose au niveau de la terre on a
fait des études génétiques récentes pour
montrer qu'en fait c'est le même sang
qui coule
dans les juifs et les Palestiniens on a
montré cette souche comme une donc le
sang qui coule c'est le sens de frère et
et en sorte et le ciel dit la même le
ciel dit la même chose je veux dire donc
il faut il faut retrouver des racines
dans la terre et des racines dans le
ciel et et transformer effectivement la
le fratricide en fraternité et c'est là
que la mémoire l'intelligence le refus
d'oublier l'origine me paraît important
il y a beaucoup d'ailleurs d'écrits en
ce moment sur la question des origines
sur l'importance du sacré même
républicain dans dans le collectif ou
même en politique un tout petit mot le
pape François que l'on s'est malade vous
a dit cette phrase à votre retour carnet
de voyage déjà écrit priez pour moi
comment vous avez compris cette phrase
j'ai cru d'abord que mon italien partait
en vrille je vais faire répéter et puis
moi j'ai rencontré un peu ce que c'est
quand même très rare il faut l'expliquer
en Vatican
j'ai eu droit à rester seul
dans la bibliothèque vaticale et nous
avons discuté et il a voulu absolument
me raccompagner à la porte et je
refusais parce que je voyais qu'il
souffrait dans ses hanches dans son
corps etc et à la porte il me dit prier
pour moi et moi je suis fils de
kinésithérapeute donc elle s'est
immédiatement je regarde sa hanche
regarde sa canne et et je pense à sa
douleur physique et là un immense
sourire devant mon incompréhension et il
me montre la bibliothèque du Vatican et
puis sans doute derrière ben le Vatican
la chrétienté mondiale et il me dit ma
charge est lourde c'est extrêmement
difficile priez pour que j'ai la force
en gros ça voulait dire moi je ne compte
pas je suis c'est la mission c'est la
mission qui compte cette humilité
m'a absolument bouleversé et c'est vrai
que j'avais en face de moi un homme qui
était porté et c'est lui qui de sa main
écrit les dernières pages de votre livre
le pape François qui poste face Eric et
maintenant c'est quand même incroyable
et ça s'appelle c'est la première fois
qu'un lit qui dans toute l'histoire de
du Vatican que un pape postface un livre
d'écrivain le défi de Jérusalem vous
suit pas à pas et pas après page dans
dans cette terre sainte qui vous a
travers é vous restez avec nous Eric
Emmanuel Schmitt c'est la dernière
partie de cette émission Les Affranchis
on les accueille tout de suite pour leur
parti pris ils vont vous faire réagir
Bertrand Périer maître Perrier bienvenue
vous nous parlez ce soir de Bilal
Hassani ce chanteur qui malheureusement
n'a pas pu tenir un concert on y revient
et puis le mot de la semaine de notre
sémiologue marie-adrigance c'est le mot
à faire mais on commence comme chaque
soir par le bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nationale nous est racontée ce soir
parti boéthenoc bonsoir Thibault bonsoir
à tous et bien l'histoire que je vais
vous raconter ce soir assez celle d'une
réhabilitation qui fait grincer des
dents le député Adrien catenens pourrait
bientôt revenir siéger au sein de son
groupe de la France insoumise c'est ce
qu'on confirmé plusieurs cadres du parti
ces derniers jours alors vous vous
rappelez sans doute qu'il avait été
sanctionné non seulement par la justice
qui l'a condamné pour violence conjugale
en décembre dernier mais aussi par ses
collègues députés de la France insoumise
exclus de son groupe pour une durée de 4
mois il siégé depuis son retour
tumultueux à l'Assemblée en janvier
dernier parmi les non inscrits cette
sanction de 4 mois arrive à dans une
semaine le groupe de la France insoumise
va donc devoir se prononcer sur sa
réintégration ou non alors qu'est-ce qui
va se passer comment ça va se dérouler
alors on est à l'assemblé alors on va
voter l'ensemble du groupe va se
prononcer mardi prochain c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le coordinateur de la France
insoumise manuel Bompard petite
subtilité cependant pour éclairer les
uns et les autres sur leur décision 4
députés du groupe ont été chargés
d'auditionner Audrey Catena au préalable
de plutôt favorable à sa cause de plutôt
des favorable les réponses qui leur
donnera sont ensuite transmises aux
autres membres du groupe qui décideront
donc mardi par un vote s'il peut ou non
les rejoindre et qu'est-ce qui pourrait
faire pencher la balance globalement il
y a une volonté de tourner la page nous
dit-on beaucoup dans le groupe Led pour
une réhabilitation estimant qu'on ne
peut pas payer indéfiniment pour ces
fautes pour autant des gestes sont
attendus beaucoup aimeraient qu'il fasse
un mea culpa sur son acte et sur sa
défense médiatique confite ainsi une
députée une autre précise ses pensées
a-t-il conscience que sa stratégie
médiatique de diabolisation de son
épouse et contraire au combat féministe
alors demain au delà de la fameuse gifle
c'est en effet les propos et la défense
médiatique d'Adrien catenas dans ses
interviews notamment à BFM qui avait
heurté alors a-t-il changé prix du recul
oui sur certains de ses proches il ne
parlait plus ainsi aujourd'hui dit l'un
d'eux il faudra en convaincre c'est
collègues Adrien catenas qui devra aussi
confirmer qu'il subit un stage de
sensibilisation sur les violences
conjugales auprès d'une association
c'était la condition qui avait été
déposée à sa réintégration a priori
c'est le cas depuis un mois donc
réintégration possible on va suivre ça
évidemment ça ne plaît pas à tout le
monde et non les trois autres groupes de
la nupes ils sont opposés mais ils ne
seront pas consultés cela fait grincer
des dents dans notre groupe si c'était
chez nous il ne reviendrait pas confie
ainsi une députée écologiste un peu
dépité du côté des socialistes on est
guère plus ravis mais on reconnaît que
la réhabilitation est déjà en cours
depuis plusieurs mois
inutile de relancer une guerre alors que
les choses se sont calmées expliquent
ainsi un député il y en aura
certainement autrement de la majorité
qui convient à pointer cette
réintégration du doigt si elle a lieu
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des craintes de
la France insoumise retour au Berka et
sillallieu risque d'affaiblir la
crédibilité du discours féministe porté
par le groupe ce sera le prix de la
camaraderie mais on va suivre ça on va
suivre ça la semaine prochaine donc
merci merci Thibault on enchaîne avec
vous Mariette le mois à faire alors on
quitte un peu le débat franco-français à
faire pour voyage d'affaires parce que
Emmanuel Macron est en Chine alors il
est parti notre président en Chine mais
justement Myriam il n'a pas été question
de voyage d'affaires mais de voyage
d'état de déplacement diplomatique donc
c'est quand même un peu curieux et donc
c'est la meilleure preuve pour vous que
il a amené avec lui une cinquantaine de
chefs d'entreprise malgré tout et donc
on parle pas on parle de voyage d'État
mais on fait des affaires exactement il
est parti avec des chefs d'entreprises
des hommes d'affaires comme l'on ne dit
pas vraiment dans notre pays donc et
c'est tout à fait utile puisque la
balance commerciale comme vous le savez
n'est pas en notre faveur avec la Chine
donc il faut passer des contrats la pour
assurer notre avenir économique donc il
veut pas parler de ce mot-là ce mot là
n'est pas prononcé je crois et ça parce
qu'il a une mauvaise réputation ça
depuis très longtemps si l'on prend
l'affaire Calas autant de Voltaire si
l'on prend l'affaire du Rainbow Warrior
autant de Mitterrand plus près de nous
l'affaire DSK voir l'affaire Benalla
cette semaine l'affaire Schiappa et
cette semaine aperçu pas alors là dans
ce cas le mot arrive alors que c'est
quand même un micro événement même si
c'est assez paradoxal qu'une ministre
féministe
posant Playmore mais comme Aurélie nos
arrières grands-parents Myriam c'est la
belle affaire
donc je crois que non il y a
sérieusement une raison beaucoup plus
profonde pour soupçonner le mot à faire
dans notre pays et qui évidemment lié à
notre rapport au monde économique voilà
ça c'est classique en France ça fait
partie de notre habitude donc quand il y
a des crises comme en ce moment bah le
monde des affaires est carrément brûlé
parfois en place de Grève ça s'est vu
bon il a il a quelque parce qu'il n'est
pas justement tellement intervenu dans
l'affaire dite des retraites bon en tout
cas pour plus du monde du business
aujourd'hui que le monde des affaires
c'est vrai exactement mais c'est le même
mot c'est un mot très innocent qu'est-ce
que c'est une affaire c'est j'ai quelque
chose à faire en deux mots et puis les
deux mots se sont agrégés mais c'est une
action une action assez basique tout à
fait innocente donc dans ce sens là ce
mot doit être défendu comme production
comme manière d'agir et voilà il a pas
de connotation morale si vous voulez et
quand on ne fait pas ça on se le fait
piquer justement par nos amis
anglo-saxons parce que par exemple
prenez afférer être très afféré en
anglais c'est être baisé et donc là en
effet on tombe sur le business et
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
françaises dans le monde médiatique
français on parle du business on parle
plus du monde des affaires ça ferait un
peu désuet de le dire quand même voilà
alors moi je veux défendre quand même
pour finir cela pour une connotation un
peu plus printanière je dirais
euh il a des connotations très frenchies
semoule à faire puisque vous savez qu'il
fait partie de la langue amoureuse avoir
et bien sûr et nous manquait cette
dimension et on se les fait piquer là
aussi par les Anglais
ça se dit plus en français alors moi je
veux bien que les Français n'aient pas
le sens de l'argent mais qu'ils perdent
leur sens de l'amour ça ça m'embête
[Rires]
elle est formidable Mariette on
réhabilite les mots hein pourquoi pas
celui-là aussi allez on termine avec
Bertrand ça va vous faire réagir j'en
suis sûr
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt vous vouliez
revenir Bertrand Perrier sur
l'annulation du concert de Bilal Hassani
c'était mercredi soir dernier à Metz oui
alors vous savez Bilal Hassani c'est ce
jeune chanteur qui avait représenté la
France à l'Eurovision en 2019 et depuis
il poursuit sa carrière de chanteur mais
bien au-delà il est un peu une icône
LGBT de la culture queer avec ces
perruques blonds platines son maquillage
excentrique ces tenues exubérante et
donc effectivement mercredi dernier il
était programmé dans une salle de
spectacle à Metz c'est une salle de
concert qui se trouve aussi être une
ancienne église oui et c'est là que
c'est important parce que vous l'avez
dit c'est une ancienne église c'était
une église c'est vrai elle a été
construite comme telle au quatrième
siècle mais depuis les années 1500 elle
n'est plus une église elle a été
désacralisée elle a donc l'aspect d'une
église mais elle en a pas la
consécration c'est donc un bâtiment
laïque depuis 5 siècles et pourtant des
groupes intégristes et catholiques ce
sont insurgés contre la venue du
chanteur voilà alors il y a notamment le
groupe Civitas qui a qualifié le concert
de provocation anti-chrétienne et de
profanation appelant même les chrétiens
à des prières face à la salle de concert
au moment de la représentation de Bilal
Hassani qui se trouve qualifié de
travesti marocain et une conseillère
régionale Front national rassemblement
national a emboîter le pas en estimant
que ce concert était un outrage en
pleine semaine sainte donc le cancer a
été finalement annulé oui le concert a
été annulé par le producteur qui a pris
l'initiative face aux menaces d'annuler
le concert alors ce soir je voudrais
dire ceci
à longueur d'interview et de chansons
Bilal Hassani ne cesse de véhiculer un
message de rassemblement de paix et de
joie c'est un garçon solaire c'est un
garçon souriant sensible positif
parfois même assez naïf mais en tout cas
c'est un garçon qui est aussi un exemple
et une aide pour beaucoup de jeunes
homosexuels en tout cas il n'y a dans
ces paroles dans sa musique pas une once
de violence on peut ne pas aimer ce
qu'il fait mais Bilala saline menace
personne Bilal Hassani ne discrimine
personne il ne faut personne n'est je
l'ai dit Bilal Hassani ne blasphème
personne puisque le lieu où il devait se
produire n'est pas un lieu sacré je
trouve inquiétant que on est interdit à
ce chanteur de s'exprimer je voudrais
qu'on le laisse au contraire chanter
quitte à ce qu'on ne l'aime pas qu'on
laisse ses fans l'applaudir et qu'on le
laisse nous bousculer nous chamboulés
nous émouvoir car comme il le dit
lui-même dans son dernier titre marathon
je cite quand tu me surprends je t'aime
je t'aime
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
de toute façon je déteste quand on se
part du catholicisme pour avoir des
positions comme ça qui sont pas des
positions d'accueil de l'autre et même
de chemin vers l'autre moi quand je dise
l'Évangile je vois exactement le
contraire que l'attitude comme ça
d'ultra catholique qui sont crispés sur
leur identité je d'ailleurs le pape dans
le livre
la nécessité du chrétien c'est d'aller
au devant de l'autre au contraire et
c'est pas du tout de de refuser sa place
c'est une vous savez il y a des livres
mais il y a des gens qui savent pas lire
et vous aimez bilani Hassani vous le
connaissez
il est extrêmement dérangeant et
extrêmement touchant parce que
dérangeant moi il m'a fait réfléchir un
peu au à Nation de gens à la notion de
sexe parce que il a pas le genre de son
sexe et il l'assume non mais c'est ça
fait du bien de voir des individus qui
tracent comme ça et il faut qu'il faut
les applaudir vous trouvez qu'il a été
assez soutenu Bertrand ou pas il a été
ce qui est ce qui est tragique bien sûr
il m'a Abdul Malak a fait part de sa
préoccupation François Grosdidier le
maire de Metz a dit que il était choqué
par l'obscurantisme de ces groupes pour
autant ce que l'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est que les catholiques
intégristes font farod en disant grosso
modo on a réussi à nos fins et donc on a
réussi à faire pour vous pardon le
producteur son producteur n'aurait pas
dû céder peut-être que finalement
François grosdiguier le maire de Metz a
dit que il était toujours invité à Metz
et que permettrait le cas échéant les
forces de l'ordre pour qu'ils puissent
tenir son concert je pense que en effet
peut-être qu'il y aurait plus avoir une
concertation avec la mairie qui aurait
permis de ne pas annuler le concert en
tout cas ce parti pris et là pour
rétablir un certain nombre de vérités
merci beaucoup merci les affranchis
d'être venu pour vos cartes blanches et
Merci à VOUS
Eric Emmanuel Schmitt le défi Jérusalem
c'est à dire chez Alba Michel bien sûr
avec une postface du Souverain Pontife
s'il vous plaît allez c'est le weekend
profitez bien à la semaine prochaine
très belle semaine
[Musique]